orioles and yankees game one of two and
a double header
well there are emergency starters and
then there are emergency starters and if
you're a reliever nowadays well you
better be ready at any given notice and
that's the case here is
tom eschelman's going to get a spot
start throwing to dj
le mayhew out to right field santander
sprinting on alberto is out and he makes
the catch
here's the powerful right-hander luke
hoyts out to left field
stewart has an opportunity
and there's the second out and that
brings up brett gardner
pitch here swinging a flare out to left
stewart tracking it a couple of steps to
his right makes the catch
when thomas hesselman takes the spot
right out of spot starter one two three
first we'll go to the bottom of the
inning michael king on the mount
today for the bronx bombers he has
really shown flashes
of outstanding stuff cedric mullins
leads off the orioles like the bunt
they lead the majors with 12 bunch
singles and mullins has seven of them
and mullet swings it it's a high fly
ball well into right field clint frazier
is back he's at the wall and it is gone
cedric mullins master of the bunt leaves
the house in the orioles strike first in
game one
it's one nothing out of the shoe now
anthony sanzondare
fly ball shallow center gardner
will put it away for the first out now
here's iglesias having a great start
rounds
and there is two way here is renato
nunez
breaking ball is popped up around short
there's ty the weight on the outfield
grass to make the catch
and i'll do it for the birds in the
first
yankees gotta have some deep thoughts in
games in which they haven't hit a home
run
this year they are all in six so uh
they're usually hitting home runs that's
what they need
gary sanchez hits one deep to left field
there it goes
see ya a long home run
well that gary is scary he homers and
the game is tied at one
and andrew velasquez at the plate with
two on and two out in a 1-1 tie in the
second
they struck him out swinging high
fastball and so king
gets out of the jam well this certainly
is in a
a real rock'em sock'em rally an e3
a bloop single right and a walk and he's
he's in a jam
so they are loaded up here's a situation
where brett gardner who hasn't batted
third very often this year
he's going to get a chance for the bases
loaded and nobody out up the middle and
a base hit to center field
wade scores here comes lemayo he'll
score
it's a two run single for brett gardner
and the yankees lead three to one
so frazier walks and the bases are
loaded so ford
hit the ball well to center field in the
second and he's over one
out towards left stewart coming in
makes the catch and no time that'll do
it for eshelman
and we'll see brandon klein come on to
face gary sanchez bases loaded one out
swing and a miss big strikeout for klein
of sanchez
and that will bring up mike talkman the
yankees really
needed to blow this game open right here
and are potentially missing another big
opportunity for them
and now he bounced up there so luke
voight crosses so it's 4-1 yankees the
rbi for talkman on the bases loaded walk
here is tyro estrada estrada
swinging a miss up top klein ends the
inning with two strikeouts
a walk and a hit batsman and baltimore
now will send up the tying run
in renato nunez and he chased the pitch
out of the zone
and nunez strikes out for the second out
and here is the left hand hitting
catcher chance cisco
and the pitches popped up his fastball's
really working king
left field talkman underneath makes the
catch
to end the inning alberto stands at
first for rio ruiz
ruiz hits this one out to deep right
field
going back frazier at the marker it's
out of room and it's
over the wall orioles make it a one-run
game you ever get this feeling when
you're about ready to go to work and you
just can't get out of bed
that's what ben heller's feeling right
here there he goes
two away nobody on orioles down by a run
bottom of the fifth for renato
nunez there's a swing and a deep fly
ball center field by nunez he has just
tied up the ball game renato nunez
sends it over the wall four for our
score
as the pop keeps coming from ronaldo the
bases are loaded with
one out for anthony santander swung on
and
popped him up it stays in bounce forward
near the stands ford
makes the catch and the run can't score
that's a big out getting the dangerous
sound down there pieces loaded two outs
and the orioles have the 395 hitting
jose
iglesias the crown ball of third lame
goes to second they get the force and
britain works
out of trouble and duhar the go ahead
run stays
stationed at second gary sanchez the
battery big spot in this game
swing and a miss a high fastball what
else would you expect
the yankees put the first two aboard
harvey gets the next three
the orioles have the winning run at
second two and two of alaikum
and the pitch cut on him as he threw a
breaking ball chapman gets out
of the inning and guess what we go to
extra innings again aaron hicks
will bat with runners at the corners and
one out hit on the ground a second
there's one valencia the first there is
two the yankee strand a pair winning run
for the orioles
90 feet away from home to end this
losing streak
the orioles going to turn to anthony
santander
and the pitch is hit in the air to left
there's talkman to make the catch and we
will go to the ninth inning
well holder has to go to second base
because they lost the
designated hitter when they put anduhar
in the field you can't make this up
and now the yankees need at least a fly
ball from andrew lying to right field it
is a basic
holder will score and duhar with the rbi
single and the yankees have a 5-4 lead
and here's clint frazier against
lakeland's
line drive left field it's a base hit in
front of mock castle it's an rbi single
for frasier
and the yankees lead 6-4 it's 6-5
the orioles are down to their final out
with brian holliday
this should do it talkman is there
and the yankees win 6-5